>> Milo: Which one shows me looking sad?
>> Krista Stephens: Milo is a humanoid
robot that is specifically designed
to work with students with autism.
He can make a sad face, he can make a
grimace, he can make a surprised face.
He does that so that the student
can look and be able to imitate.
>> Audrey: When he was two, my
pediatrician brought it to my attention
that Nathaniel was not speaking.
He said, "You may need to get him
looked at, he may have some things going
on that you're unaware of,"
and that's when it came
to our attention that
Nathaniel had autism.
It was intense.
He couldn't tell me what his needs were.
I had to figure it out.
It took him a while to actually
start to point to things.
He started when he was three
years old here at Lester,
in their preschool program,
and it was a success.
They have all kind of tools, resources
I wouldn't have begun to think about.
>> Janette Williams: Our school
specializes in autism. At Lester,
we provide a whole realm of services.
We have speech, we have OT,
PT, extended nursing services,
and then assistive technology.
>> Krista Stephens: Milo works with the
student on a different set of modules.
It's nice because it scaffolds as
far as how difficult the modules are.
Nathaniel is working on the
happy, angry and sad module.
So he started out recognizing
Milo happy.
Then he had to choose
between happy and sad.
Then they go between
three different emotions.
So he's having to visually discriminate
between those three emotions.
>> Brian Denny: We started participating
with Milo in October of 2017.
We thought it was a unique
opportunity for us to be able
to provide our high autism population
with a service they probably
wouldn't get anywhere else.
>> Cassandra: I had read about
Milo, and the first thing I asked
when I got here was, "Hey, do
you guys have Milo? I want to get
down with this, I'm interested."
For years, nothing else was working
but now JJ has been progressing.
There's less prompting, there's
more independent thought.
>> Brian Denny: We've seen
students respond to Milo
where they might not
respond to another adult.
Children with autism, they
pick up on human affect,
but Milo doesn't have any
emotion, doesn't get upset.
Milo didn't have to stay up
too late the night before.
None of that effects Milo, he
responds the same way every time.
>> Krista Stephens: The changes
that I have seen is they are able
to follow directions better and
their visual attention is better.
It's a challenge every day to
try to get my students to sit,
focus and answer questions
and do a task.
So if I can get Milo
to help me with that,
that's another way to reach my kids.